it's just a couple of hundred meters to
the port of Lester's the place that mal
Farooq fears the most from they are
refugees are now being deported back to
Turkey along with 250 other refugees as
malice hiding from the Greek authorities
in a makeshift camp we are fair because
we have no idea what they will do with
us we spend lots of money to make this
journey to EU and we have no background
not sportive because we have belong to
poor families our people are their poor
it's rumored that Greek authorities will
swoop on the camp in the next few days
people stranded here no they have little
chance of asylum in Greece tensions are
running high and many say they'll commit
suicide if they're sent back to Turkey
and the refugee camp Moria people have
little choice but to await their
deportation razor wire keeps the
migrants inside the camp and keeps press
and public out the refugee camp at Moria
has become like a prison filming is
strictly prohibited and for the refugees
stranded here there is no escape from
here several hundred will be reported to
Turkey in the coming days human rights
organizations call this procedure a
breach of international law down at
lesbos ports two passenger boats are
ready for the next transfer nobody knows
exactly who will be on board and when
they will have to leave but for many
behind this gate the dream of a new life
in Europe will soon come
critics say a deal has been done at the
expense of the migrants well-being
well the eu-turkey deal is based on two
fundamental ideas and we think both of
them are wrong so on the one hand it
says that Greece is ready and able to
process people individually to give them
an individual process and in this eylem
system that can function that way now
secondly it's based on the notion that
Turkey is a safe country for return and
we just demonstrated that Turkey
isn't right now back in the makeshift
camp boomers arrived these migrants have
heard that two of their friends killed
themselves just after they arrived in
Turkey nobody knows if the story is true
or not but the sense of desperation is
real